what concerns you the most  about politics in the united states  today my greatest concern is a headline  that just popped up last week which is a  dramatic drop in americans believing in  god and you should recognize it as a big  problem even if you don't believe in god  this is  the predictor of everything else people  are fond of saying that politics is  downstream of culture  culture is downstream of religion cult  and culture come from the same root word  what a culture  worships defines that culture and a  culture that worships god is going to be  a better society and a culture that  worships money is not going to be as  good a society and a culture that  worships sex is not going to be as good  of a society to quote john adams the u.s  constitution is built for a moral and  religious people he says the  constitution is not fit for any other  kind of people and so if we lose that we  lose the country